Scientists, you know, those guys that define
our society in the shadows, have recently
performed a study that’s come to the conclusion
that the human brain judges the trustworthiness
of person based on their facial features.
Dope.
Hey Guys, I’m Will from Sourcefed, guest
hosting for DNews.
Researchers here in the US, the place that
loves faces more than anywhere else, we invented
instagram, have found that brain activity
changes in response to how trustworthy a person
looks, based on just a fleeting look at their
face.
Coincidentally, they found out more information
leading to why humans make certain preconceived
judgments.
The research found that portions of our brain
are doing more subconscious work than previously
thought.
I just thought hot girls were hot, it turns
out my brain is smarter than me.
Jonathan Freeman from New York University,
resident smart-man stated “we form spontaneous
judgments of other people that can be largely
outside awareness.”
Which is how smart people say, “sometimes
our brains are mean and sometimes not.”
The study published in the Journal of Neuroscience
focused largely on the actions of the amygdala,
the small almond shaped part deep inside your
brain.
I google imaged it and it’s kind of gross
as is everything inside of your body but fun
to learn about!
The amygdala plays a role in processing strong
emotions, so every time that Starbucks barista
gave you a chai tea latte with soy instead
of skim milk, that’s what’s been making
you feel that way.
Before the study, Freeman asked a group of
individuals to rate whether they trusted certain
individuals based on their faces.
Which I like to call High School orientation.
People surprisingly tended to agree on which
faces were trustworthy or not.
Apparently faces with several key features
like furrowed eyebrows and shallower cheekbones
are consistently rated as less trustworthy.
So basically, nobody trusts Benedict Cumberbatch.
Another group was instructed to lay in an
MRI scanner while they saw faces flash on
a screen.
Each face only flashed for milliseconds.
Which is more than enough time for me personally
to judge someone.
Just tell me a dudes name and I’m already
mad.
But even though their eyes had small glimpses
of the images, they still were unaware they’d
seen the faces.
Even because of this, the amygdala still responded
differently to trustworthy and untrustworthy
faces.
That means our brains are quicker at judging
than our eyes are.
Freeman also proposed that the biggest question
of the study is whether or not the brain activity
somehow altered how people behave.
He stated, “even though people might not
have conscious awareness, they might move
back very subtly when perceiving an untrustworthy
face, but that is still unknown.”
Apparently Freeman was never a freshman in
High School.
What do you guys think?
Have you ever looked at someone and loved
them just because?
Let me know in the comments down below!
And if you trust my face, you can see more
of it over at Sourcefed.
Thanks for watching.